Barry's eyepieces drop down and you can
definitely see a glowing heads-up
display interface inside those goggles
which practically must have to move fast
enough buffering wise to keep up with
very speed to be able to navigate him so
even his technology has to be as fast as
he is because you know if it was just
like Google Maps or Waze in there Barry
would totally outrun how slow that crap
is because when it's me and I like Veer
off on an exit it takes it like a solid
10 seconds to just know where I am and
with my ability to drive and navigate
it's like in the middle of a lake I love
the street stretching into this kind of
hyperspace as he's about to take off the
pavement around Barry's foot though
stays in place only
followed by a speed force which seems to
be the trigger that kicks him forward if
you go through this slingshot effect
frame by frame Barry's first lunge
motion keeps him in the air as he
continues to speed forward so that
really in a single stride he moves an
entire city block
[Music]